the uh format for this evening is pretty
simple really each of our
speakers Andrew arguing that Napoleon
should be called The Great and Adam
arguing that he shouldn't we'll speak
for about 12 minutes or so uh then we'll
have a bit of Ary barie for a few
minutes uh and then you'll all be free
to ask any question you wish no matter
how rude it may be uh and do feel free
please to take part in in that part of
the debate each of tonight's historians
and they're both distinguished
historians uh have
written has
written an enormous book um here we are
the other way around this one is
heavier uh each comes in its own parcel
Force
truck should you order them from Amazon
uh the proposition we G to discuss is
Andrew's claim that Napoleon should be
called great there is no question mark
in his assessment on the spine of this
book it's just Napoleon the Great by
Andrew
Roberts
now Andrew as you know is a very
distinguished historian who has
made the business of Napoleon and what
Napoleon got up to one of his main
interests in life he is the keep in many
ways of the Napoleonic flame his books
include Napoleon and bonapart Napoleon
and Wellington sorry an investigation
into the relationship between the two
generals waterl Napoleon's last Gamble
and his latest Napoleon the great is
also going to be the subject of a TV
series which starts on the BBC next year
isn't it next year yes as I say he's
going to have 12 minutes or so to lay
out his
case
now it's often struck me that bre was
pretty right when he said happy is the
land that has no need of Heroes and I
was trying to think of anyone in British
history who is called the great and I
could only think of Alfred and I only
know him as great because of his baking
achievements rather in the spirit of the
times I suppose
but why Andrew is going to make the case
that Napoleon should be called great
when I Googled what did Napoleon do for
France the other day I learned that he
took the country to war had the country
declare him Emperor nationalized
anything he felt like nationalizing and
introduced a secret
police now we have heard of him of
course we've all heard of him he used to
be used to terrify children in this
country he certainly won battles he was
everyone agrees a brilliant General he
rebuilt cities he invented a legal
system he's even responsible for the
street numbering system is he not that
still pertains in most of this country
with odd numbers on one side of the
street and even numbers on the
other but what is it about this man who
even Andrew In This Very lengthy book
which I had the pleasure of finishing
this morning just in time
admits was a pretty sanguinary fellow at
times what is it about him that makes
him so great so Andrew tell us
why can I borrow the uh the bottom book
there the bottom yeah you could learn
something from it I know it's a
wonderful
book ladies and gentlemen it's a great
honor to be invited to address you and
to answer Jeremy's question
the central point about Napoleon is the
way in which he saved France and to
understand the dangers that uh he
overcame in the course of this I'd like
to quote from a extremely good book a
phantom Terror written by Adam
zi um and what Adam writes on page 77
quite rightly
is when he became first Consul and
effective dictator of France in 1799
Napoleon had been faced by IND
describable chaos resulting from 10
years of Revolution and
counterrevolution in sign political
struggle random political Terror class
war and open Civil War in some parts of
the country the authority of the state
had been undermined by the rapid
succession of governments Each of which
overturned the legitimacy of its
predecessor the law had been turned into
a tool by rival political factions and
Justice had been
politicized uh Napoleon may have been a
product of of the Enlightenment and what
conservatives saw as its depraved values
but he was a pragmatist if he did not
believe in divine right he certainly had
no time for jacobine ideology Illuminati
or dreamers of any kind he believed in
order and he knew how to impose it so
what did he do with this order well the
first thing as uh as Jeremy pointed out
was the code Napoleon he ripped up the
42 often contradictory legal systems
that had so held France back
and instead had one single code which
was from then on been able to uh to
basically make France into a modern
State and it's been adopted by 40
countries of the world in every
inhabited continent he also created the
glories of Paris when you go on a
romantic weekend to uh to Paris you will
walk along the keys that were built by
Napoleon the great you will cross one of
the Four Bridges uh built by Napoleon
the great you will see the vondom column
in the pl vondom or the arct the trium
carousel in the Lou it is partly because
of him that it is such a glorious and
beautiful city today he built also the
the useful things like the reservoirs
and the uh and the sewers he was a true
creator he created the bank de France
which is the uh still around and of
course at the time was the reason that
he was able to get inflation down from
10,000% a year
to 6% a year he was the man who ended
the war in the Von day this incredibly
vicious war that had claimed 40,000
lives more than were guillotined in the
terror and he ended that uh that war
he's the man Napoleon the great who is
behind the system of prefects in
departments there were Departments of
course before but he managed to
centralize that system with the prefects
which again we have today he set up the
con deta um which meets every Wednesday
today um in in uh able to to vet the
laws of France he managed also to
organize the first proper public
accounting system and he also reformed
the tax code he did the things that you
need to do in order to make a country
work he set up ladies and gentlemen the
Leon Don which is still quite rightly
coveted by Frenchmen and he also signed
the concordat which brought to anend end
the uh horrific system of uh of
discrimination against Christians in the
French Revolution which had led to the
desecration of the altars and the deaths
of hundreds of nuns and priests so when
his mother Madame mayor was asked about
Napoleon about Napoleon's achievements
and she said so long as they last she
was right in a sense or at least so long
since she last they she wasn't to know
that they have lasted they have lasted
200 years and uh they alone quite apart
from anything to do with fighting or
conquests or Wars or battles um mean
that when you vote this evening uh you
should vote um you should vote Yes they
seek to destroy the Revolution by
attacking my person he said in 1804
after an assassination attempt of him
one on one of 30 assassination attempts
uh that he survived um uh I will defend
it for I am the revolution and this was
right what he did was to save the best
bits of the Revolution uh equality
before the law religious toleration uh
the abolition of feudalism and he got
rid of the he just Swept Away the worst
Parts the um the 10day calendar The Cult
of the Supreme Being the um and the
terror the uh the mass
guillotining and in a sense one can
understand why uh he felt that it was
necessary to do all of this and why also
the British and indeed the old
legitimists uh the Onan regime old
reactionary Powers desperately wanted to
get rid of him and uh it was Spencer
persal the British prime minister who
wrote in a book entitled caty title this
uh the observations intended to point
out the application of a prophecy in the
11th book of David to the French power
um you wouldn't allow Publishers
wouldn't allow you get away with that uh
as a title any longer um and this book
um this book said that the Bible
foretold the death of Napoleon and that
the world would end in
1926 uh when finally Spencer Bal was
assassinated by somebody even more
deranged than him uh in 1812 his mantle
as prime minister was taken out by Lord
Liverpool who was also completely
committed to the destruction of Napoleon
and it was important of course to create
this bogeyman figure that Jeremy say was
used quite rightly was used to scare
children but the fact is 200 years later
we can now appreciate that that he was a
great man not somebody that needed to be
um used for uh for for propaganda he
also was a man with a great sense of
humor which you don't get in in Monsters
he was uh when at the Opera an escape
lunatic from a lunatic asylum came up
and told him that uh he was in love with
the empress uh Napoleon replied you seem
to have chosen a curious person for your
Confidant uh and when the Archbishop
deran um wrote him a letter on the eve
of the coronation saying that he would
willingly give his life for Napoleon uh
Napoleon noted on the uh on the letter
pay 12,000 Franks to the Archbishop out
of the theatrical
fund and then when all his uh brothers
and sisters were trying to um were were
were arguing and complaining about the
various principalities and and uh
countries that they've been assigned in
the Napoleon Napoleonic Empire um
Napoleon Shrugged and said you'd have
thought that I'd been misappropriating
the legacy of our late father the
king he wasn't a warmonger there were
seven wars that were um seven wars of
the Coalition that were uh declared
against him and he did attack uh both um
uh Spain and Portugal in 1807 and 1808
and of course Russia in 1812 two Wars
that he started against the seven that
were declared against revolutionary in
Napoleonic France if you're looking for
an inveterate warmonger you have to go
back to the British who were funding all
of those seven coalitions to a huge uh
to a huge degree and rightly so he
wanted to invade us we you know I'm I'm
delighted that the British won the
Battle of waloo as an Englishman it set
up the British British Empire very
nicely after 1815 but it doesn't mean
that we still have to be inth to the old
propaganda of the um of the cartoonists
the caricaturists like Thomas rolinson
and James gilray and George krook shank
that make out this uh this man to be a
monster what's more he didn't have a
Napoleon complex this idea that there
was a hubristic concept where he had to
go around invading uh countries is
completely absurd the way in which we
try to fit his career into hubris versus
Nemesis this old uh ancient Greek drama
dramatic um conceit just simply doesn't
work the reason he invaded Russia in
18122 was because he had beaten the
Russians twice before he' fought in
blizzards before he had the largest army
in the history of the world it was the
same size as the whole population of
Paris twice the size of the Russians he
had no intention of going to Moscow he
wanted to fight within 20 days along the
borders of Russia uh he had no idea that
typhus was going to kill 140,000 of his
men he had no idea that the Russians
were going to fight such a scorched
Earth policy that they would allow they
would actually burn down Moscow or at
least three quarters of
it so uh and he tried to stop several
times on the way to Moscow as I say he
had no intention of going there when he
started that war and he did know about
the winter um which is why he allowed
himself 3 weeks to get back to smallin
he made a terrible mistake after the
battle of malaro slavit um but the idea
that he had no concept of the Russian
winter is absurd he'd read Charles the
12th the book by voler and knew
perfectly well that it did so it's not
he's not a matter of hus he was defeated
but plenty of people have been defeated
in history and are still great Peter the
Great Lost the aov campaign um Frederick
the great lost the battle of Colin
Katherine the Great Lost the war against
Sweden uh Alfred the Great Lost so many
battles he spent most of his time in the
uh in the marshes of athl but it doesn't
stop them from being great and neither
should it stop Napoleon he was a great
meritocrat 10 of his uh Marshals came
from the working classes a fact totally
unknown in the history of France up
until then they were the sons of Coopers
and Tanners and BFFs and inke Keepers
and Millers uh one of them actually um
claimed to have had a royal claimed that
his father had had a royal appointment
but the Royal appointment was in fact
the Royal molecatcher
uh so in a sense you could actually add
him as well and make uh make 11 of the
marshals Winston Churchill said that
Napoleon was the greatest man of action
since Julius Caesar and I believe he's
also his life is a standing rebuke to
people who don't believe in the uh great
man theory of history and who think that
history is all created like the marxists
do by vast impersonal forces standing
against that ladies and gentlemen is the
career and life of Napoleon and um one
of the midshipman on HMS bapan which uh
that Napoleon surrendered to and uh was
taken back to uh to Plymouth on in said
he showed us what one little human
creature like ourselves can accomplish
in a span so short and that ladies and
gentlemen is so true and one of the
major reasons why tonight you should
vote yes thank you very much
[Applause]
indeed
you well now to make the case that there
is no argument for calling Napoleon
great we have another distinguished
historian Adam zisi his book books
include the bestselling epic about
Napoleon's biggest blunder although
apparently according to Andrew just now
he couldn't really help himself uh 1812
Napoleon's fatal march on Moscow and its
sequel rights of Passage he's also
written the fall of Napoleon and the
Congress of Vienna his latest book is
Phantom Terror the threat of revolution
in the repression of Liberty 1789 to
1848 Adam is as you will deduce from
this about as much of a fan of Napoleon
as Nigel farage is of David
Cameron so uh Adam give us the feat of
Cl in fact give us the whole corpse
really thank you well first of all I
must thank you for this opportunity to
lose my virginity at my grand old age um
and then many thanks to intelligence
Squad um and and to Jeremy for sharing
this
um this is uh indeed an impressive book
Thank you for quoting from my book um
although it's slightly out of
context
this my words weren't meant as an
approval um this book is absolutely
marvelous I picked it up Andrew very
kindly sent me a copy I picked it up and
I opened it and I said to myself go he's
got a nerve putting the author
photograph on the end papers until I
until I suddenly
realized that it was
was in Napoleon I then turned to the
title page and I read Andrew Roberts in
big capitals and I thought oh who's this
book about and underneath it said neodon
the
great ladies and gentlemen it is a very
good book I recommend it it's a rattling
good read um made all the more enjoyable
if as you read about Napoleon strutting
the European stage and making making a
rightful Nuance to himself you
superimpose on your mental image of him
Andrew's
[Applause]
face seriously um Napoleon should have
been called the
great history gave him several unique
opportunities to reinvigorate his
country to restore its prosperity and
influence to make it the dominant power
on the
continent and to make most of Europe a
better
place instead of which he messed
up he succeeded in ruining France's
position in Europe for several decades
if not in the entire 19th
century he hugely built up the power of
her greatest enemy Great
Britain and he provoked a great increase
rise in the power of both Russia and
Prussia both of which inflicted both of
which resulted in very unfavorable uh
consequences for Europe and indeed
France Andrew says he was a great man of
action so does Churchill apparently and
this is always what we hear of him the
doer the
achiever
well one could go on about this but um
since the subject of virginity came up
funny enough in um
1787 um the 18-year-old young officer
Napoleon decided it was time he lost his
so he sauntered off to the red light
district of Paris the P Royale and
picked up a tart and took her home and
um did his business the next morning
being the person he was he wrote the
whole episode up and we have this now
the most interesting thing about this
account is that it transpires that he
had attempted three times before to pick
up Tarts now excuse me if a young
officer can't pick up a
tart I
mean I don't see that as some Mark of
the great achiever in
1793 he went off to Corsica to bring the
revolution to his native Island he made
such a holix of it that the entire
family had to get on board a French ship
and be evacuated while their family
house was sacked by the angry
populace
um at the moment at The crucial moment
of the K of which was to bring him to
power he completely mocked up he barged
into the Assembly of the
oan um trumpeting ludicrous phrases
about the God of Fortune and the God of
War March behind me everybody laughed
him out and he had to retreat Retreat
out of the door under a hail of abuse um
only rescued by a couple of grenadiers
he then marched into the other assembly
where he was beaten up and injected and
he sat around in a state of total
dejection not knowing what to do next
and it was only because his younger
brother lucier took the upper hand and
sent in the troops that anything came of
it one could quote endless um cock-ups
of this kind um in his
life now he's usually also thought of as
the great military genius well yeah he
did win a few battles but when you take
a close look at the great the famous
ones you know moringo everybody says
fantastic well he Jolly nearly lost that
and the reason the only reason he won it
was because the Austrian General thought
he'd already won it and went home to
have
lunch and at that moment Napoleon's
reinforcements arrived and a completely
un planned charge by um General
Kellerman totally flamu the aans who all
started running um the other great
victory at arala was a complete nonsense
I mean he never got on the bridge well
there are two accounts one says he never
got on the bridge the other one says he
got on the bridge but fell off it into
the into the bog below um the reason
these um victories
were um perceived as being so great was
because he shamelessly wrote them up as
such lying through his teeth uh about
numbers and um results he was the most
fantastic spin
doctor um you know even even AIT his
greatest Victory well you know it's
partly the fact that kusov his opponent
refused to adopt his own plan and just
sat there saying it's all going to be a
mess anyway and nothing's going to work
um so the Russian forces weren't even
being properly directed
and he originally was helped by the fact
that
he he was up against very old generals
commanding armies of an 18th century
type which just sort of ploted along
stood in line short and then waited you
know either to advance or Retreat
whereas he adopted tactics he encircled
them and so on the point is that they
all gradually leared from him and from
their mistakes he never learned from his
mistakes he carried on the same old
tactics um with less energy as he grew
older they learned to improve to bring
in new Weaponry uh the British famously
brought in the
rifle uh the Russians brought in
extraordinary aiming devices um to their
artillery he did nothing he carried on
with the old equipment um of the 18th
century and just thrw more men into the
breach whenever he needed it he got
sloppy and that's why he began to lose
and he didn't think um that tactics that
could work
in rich countries like Northern Italy or
Southern Germany couldn't work in Spain
where there was no fodder no forage no
food no water anything or let alone
Russia
and he therefore presided over well the
greatest military
disaster rarely of of History which is
the Russian campaign he went to war
without any War aims his War aim if you
put it down to this was you could liken
he really wanted he he set off to war
with the greatest army anybody's ever
collected in Europe in order to try and
persuade the other guy to become his
ally you know it's a bit like um
thinking you're going to get your
girlfriend back by going burning down
her house and beating her
up um he went in with no war aims he
completely ignored par Andrew the
climate kept teasing kakur who'd spent
three years out in Russia saying H
kangur is trying to scare us with the
Russian winter it's perfectly nice look
at it he was saying in in in in October
um he took no account of that he
wouldn't take the advice of people who
told him to shoe his horses um he
presided over the greatest military cups
in history not least waterl which he
should have won and I mean almost
everything he did that day which Andrew
Andrew himself points out um was as
though he'd meant to lose
it his
diplomacy his
politics International politics were no
better at first he began he followed the
Revolutionary um theme of exporting the
revolution he then decided to
turn to to a more um conventional role
and he followed the traditional French
World the patent set by Lou the 14 of
the f p defam whereby they put boror on
the Thrones of Spain and Naples thereby
guaranteeing themselves
allies so he put his brothers on Thrones
except instead of letting them become
popular in those countries bring those
countries to a state of prosperity and
um efficiency from which they could have
helped France he continually undermined
them um pulled resources out and turn
succeeded in turning all those um States
into either useless burdens such as
Spain or um states which came out
against him such as Naples under mua in
the end um every single Alliance he
made he laid down terms ter which were
simply not bearable to the Ally and he
just bullied and treated the Allies as
vassals as a result gradually he was
left with not one single Ally anywhere
which is not really a very clever way of
operating as for his great achievements
in France the Cod Napoleon wasn't
written by him it was written by comares
and a group of other people Napoleon's
only contribution he'd suddenly come in
and and offer sort of what he thought
was common sense when they were trying
to decide whether which of a pair of
twins should be regarded as the first
born he said well it's obvious isn't it
um what went in first comes out second
so the second child out it's got to be
the first
born good corsan philosophy no doubt but
you know that was his contribution to
the C
Napoleon
um yes He restored Law and Order only
then to break it in the most fantasticly
callous way to trample law yes there was
equality before the law but not if he
didn't like you if he didn't like you it
was worse than the oan regime let the C
you sent off um to vanen or or or or
Guana or or or simply
exiled he uh he was a terrible awful
prude and a PRI and he brought this into
his awful little small town morality
into public life you know some official
would be seen somewhere with his
mistress publicly he'd say this is not
possible you can't be seen like that he
repudiated when Josephine became when he
became first Consul he he made her give
up all her friends who had a a bit of a
past you know nice girls that she'd be
what she had quite a past and so all her
friends were gone on um he was
continually sort of um bringing this
this this um culture in
and at the same time he in order to gain
influence and friends and to reward
people he would give money and position
he was always bribing people you know
somebody' come along and say give him
some money give him a position make him
a prefere or something and what he
introduced into French public life
was a tremendous sense of um everything
was based on property on money and
service to the state but all to do based
on money and
um and loyalty to him and any Minister
who suggests
did um a course of action he didn't
agree with would be immediately made to
feel his displeasure and very often lose
his job for it not even for
contradicting him simply saying when
asked his advice what would you do you
know and he'd say I would would do this
sire and if he didn't like the idea this
man was
out finally the
man well
he didn't rarely have friends he only
had cultures yes he cried when Lan was
killed he cried when Duro was killed but
he
um he didn't really treat any of them as
friends he treated them extremely badly
he would berate senior officers even
Marshals in front of juniors in the most
disgusting
way and he was always always
persecuting um people he didn't like for
instance he was a racist he didn't like
black so General jumar a very very brave
General was sidelined and wasn't allowed
to have the leion on because you
couldn't give it to a
black um he hated women having any
influence at all and treated them like
dir he was his his uh persecutions of
people like Madame
Dy were legendary for well she wasn't
allowed to live in Paris because people
went to her salon and they talked and he
didn't like them talking CU they might
talk about him unfavorably so she was
exiled endlessly exiled and if anybody
went to see her even when met Madame
ramier passing through Switzerland went
to dropped in on her she was then
penalized and told she had to move out
of
Paris um unbelievably unpleasant poor
old General kulaku the grand e was
forced to go as ambassador to Russia
which he didn't want to
do he was forced to by an opponent who
said
okay if you go and spend two years there
as my
Ambassador I will allow you because of
course he wouldn't allow anybody to
marry anybody he he had to give his
ascent and he said I will allow you to
marry your mistress the woman you love
Madame de canesi
after three years kakor came
back and Napoleon exiled Madame de cani
from Paris so they couldn't see each
other only because kakur kept warning
him about the fact that it was not a
good idea to invade
Russia Napoleon the great ladies and
gentlemen not to
me Napoleon the bungler Napoleon the
bully and Napoleon the unbelievably
Petty thank you very
much well thank you very much uh Adam
I've got some bad news for you though
the preliminary vote the vote that
people cast before they'd be exposed to
your argument was for the proposition
that he should be called the Great
49% against it 24% but 27% not knowing
so perhaps you'll have persuaded them
but we'll see congratulations
Andrew an uninformed audience um well un
unexposed to your view anyway no and
sorry sorry sorry and also your view
because in your 2011 book Empire you
call Napoleon a despot he was a despot
no he was not a despot tell this is the
moderator ladies and
gentlemen can you just remind us how he
was elected well actually he he had
three great uh
referendum pbits that were slightly uh
fraudulently manipulated but they were
manipulated he actually won by we have
the actual uh the proper voting for uh
figures in the National Archives the
great thing is that um he won about 80%
but claimed
95% now that is obviously outrageous and
disgraceful and Despicable but he still
won
80% of those who dared to
vote does the word coup mean anything to
you yes yeah yes it certainly does he as
you admit in your book he and he came
and yes of course he came to power in a
in a military coup and thank God he did
because look at all the wonderful things
he did for France whereas if you try to
change the French constitution in hang
on please in um in uh 1799 it would take
three years it had to go through both
houses of Parliament and be past three
years three times so you actually had to
have and then have a pleit so you
actually took nine years to change the
Constitution is not absolutely not what
it is is an argument for having somebody
who is able to cut through all that red
tape and actually get things
done Adam is there nothing you admire
about this man oh no I I was I was
brought up rather admiring him and I
always thought um you know there was
something very sort of Dashing about
him the more one very short to dash
really wasn't he no well no when he was
young he was sort of quite sexy in a way
but you know um he wasn't a short ass no
he was not a short ass he was 5' taller
than you he was exactly my height
I when when I was making this BBC TV
series I I actually when nobody was
looking in in the room in which he died
I lay on his deathbed um and uh and my
feet just touched the end of the of the
bed he's exactly the same height then
people the reason people think that he's
tiny is because of all those
caricaturists um who constantly made him
minute against huge John bull figures
and George the thir figures he was he
was the exact average age for Frenchman
of his no people were always remarking
that he was of small stat only tall
people and he was very
[Laughter]
puny okay apart from his stature is
there anything you admire about him
um he did he did he could he was capable
of Acts of generosity he did do some
very um you know he he he did want win
some extraordinary battles he did do
some things but you know genus great you
know no he wasn't a military genius
military genius he rubbish at sea but he
was no yeah military genius doesn't take
half a million men off into the middle
of nowhere and get them all slaughtered
Massac or di of disease and and then
bring himself down you know you may not
mean to do something but if a gen you're
a genius you um you make sure that you
know what you're doing before you set
off he got look he got defeated that's
that it doesn't stop you as I mentioned
earlier all these other people who got
who were still called the Great who got
defeated but he w 46 of his 60 battles
and that is an astonishing achievement
in for anyone uh yes of course the ones
that really mattered the ones at the end
the Battle of watero he lost and he was
and he deserved to lose as I me as I say
in the book he that was a series of of
blunders the really important ones he
didn't win and that's the trouble he he
no and by the way by the way when you
criticize Morango um that is completely
outrageous when you say and then
reinforcements happen to arrive who asks
for the reinforcements you know he did
he went from that moment that he
realized the attack the Austrian attack
was taking place at 9:30 in the morning
he sent out the demands to uh Desi to
return to the battle and they did it at
the key and decisive moment so it's not
fair really to uh to slag offs 46
victories and make such a fuss of seven
defeats how many deaths do you think he
should have on his conscience all of the
ones in in Russia that's half a million
which is half a million but not but not
the 3 and a half million that died in
Napoleonic Wars in wars that were
declared on him or his allies a half
million compared to the SE the yeah a
seventh of the number of people who di
there's also a small detail of the
hundreds of thousands of Civilian deaths
as a result of the Russian
campaign um and indeed of Civilian
deaths in in in France as a result of
the oh speaking of the um the battles in
France when you say that he I think I've
got the exact
quote um um now you say that um that as
he got as he got on and as he got slower
he got worse and worse and worse what
about the four victories in 5 days in
the 1814 campaign that was one of the
great campaigns in history it's as good
as anything he did in Italy 20 years
earlier he was not getting worse he was
just getting fewer soldiers he had
70,000 against 350,000 he was just
getting sloppy and lazy had the more
soldiers than anybody had' ever had in
Russia look what a Messi made I'm
talking about the 1814 campaign you've
got to admit that that was one of the
very few soldiers he actually W up and
did something for but it was a bit late
and also you know the military genius he
he he left all those garrisons sitting
sitting in in in Poland and and Prussia
um and you know when he started the 1813
campaign he said I've got 400,000 men
except 200 of them were sitting in
fortresses from Danzig down to zos which
he believed he was going to be able to
relieve the uh the after the battle of
Dresden in 1813 he had every chance of
of relieving those men and then he'd
have had an extra 200,000 and what would
he have been able to he had every chance
but he didn't have a chance no because
he no because he lost the battle of
leig if you look one of his seven
defeats you know oh dear what a shame
never
mind we good idea not to fight them then
well so when let's let's go through that
so not to fight them all0 what
but they they're fought they're fought
get if he's invaded or his allies
invaded as in the war of the third
Coalition in 1805 what's he supposed to
do just sit back and allow that to
happen of course not he was not you see
despot Menace you know this is the
moderator he was he was so not a menace
to anyone he never went to water with
anyone between 1800 and 1805 throughout
the entire consulate he first consulate
he did not go to war with anyone and
what happened the austrians invaded and
attacked Bavaria his ally because he was
a menace
because he was at because he was taking
over Spain and Italy and and and
dominating half of Europe and ruining
everybody with his wretched blockade
people were you know people who started
the blockade the British with the orders
in Council that also the protectionism
that ultimately did bring him down but
he didn't have to do Tit for Tat you
don't always have to because you know
you fight a protectionist war by just by
just um allowing them to put um tariffs
on your business and then you do nothing
to their trade whatsoever come on when
that ever happen Okay let's look at
something Beyond military though yes you
would accept wouldn't you that this
man's Legacy in terms of science in
terms of urban planning in terms of the
law these this is
significant in terms of um science uh I
think it had very little to do with him
it was it was the legacy of the
Revolution he promoted it yeah he
promoted it whoever would have been
ruling France would have promoted it it
wasn't you know it was a movement that
had started the re I don't think the
would have gone anywhere um the the uh
revolution had Unleashed such talent and
such energy that that was one thing as
for the law all it created was the
bossiest most awful control freak system
of government which which we in in this
in Europe are now sort of fighting with
at every um you know he created
something that generates bureaucracy and
regulation um fantastic he's now to
blame for the European Union which
wasn't set up until 100 years after he
died you just been saying Europe has
embraced his I can we go back to S and
Science and uh and the the the fact is
that he was the one who set up the great
scientific prizes he was the one who uh
for the first time in French history
gave scientists made scientists into
into important people in society gave
them pures you know the first scientist
that we ever made appear in this country
Lord Kelvin in 1896 the first artist who
ever got a peage uh was Lord Leighton in
1892 the first poet who he he he made
these Great Men uh into great men and
the first poet in this country was
Tennyson in 1884 that is ridiculous it's
because it's a way of thanking people
they oh by the way he brought in life
Pages which we didn't do in this country
till 1958 that's is it yes it's a it's a
way of well what you prefer the
hereditary version that we had in this
country at the time are Democrats you
know
the point is that he Unleashed so much
human potential through his belief in
meritocracy that he is definitely worth
what it's astonishing this debate is
taking place he of
course he of course is uh deserves the
title The Great some of the arguments
are certainly astonishing he was you
would have found him absolutely go you
know what he used to do his his idea of
um thinking it was a nice thing to do
he'd take somebody and pinch their ear
or their nose or their cheeks until
blood ran and that was you know it's
like giving somebody a friendly Pat and
they were all standing there with tears
pouring down their face with running
down terrified because you know if they
said look look matey don't do this
please they might find themselves um you
know they'd be losing their jobs or be
sent sent off to toil I mean absolutely
not what happened not what happened when
he used to tug people's ears and squeeze
their noses they and we we have
so many in so many in so many different
in so many yes there are there are
accounts and there and one of them is in
my book where the guy comes away and
shows his his men after the parade he
goes look the emperor this is what the
emperor did to me I know he loves me he
knows me he was never blood show me a
place where culture of Si of fancy that
is quite disgusting not in the STIs no
they no he was a genuinely charismatic
figure and they and they quite l Al
adored working with him his friends when
you said he didn't have friends what an
outrageous remark to me you didn't you
didn't make you didn't mention uh besser
you didn't mention Desai he had plenty
of people who was able to to um to be
friendly with the drawback was of course
that they all died in battle all four of
them um died in uh in battle and so yeah
as his life went on he had few and few
friends but it doesn't mean that he was
incapable of the concept of
friendship what about his incompetence
with
women well um he himself claimed to have
had six or seven Mistresses I've named
22 uh in that so if that's incompetence
hey right yes I mean they weren't
Mistresses 22 I mean there were girls
he's left with because he'd come along
say come along I'm Emperor you know and
he'd give them one but I mean you know
that's not exactly a mistress yeah he
was he was much loved by um by two um
very stupid woman women um Mario Louise
his second wife and um and Mar VV is his
and Josephine wasn't the brain of
Britain really love him she yeah no
that's true she didn't really love him
it's a much more complex story than the
kind of Romeo and Juliet um love story
that is much more complex and much more
interesting and much more human in my
view as
well right let's have um let's have some
contributions from the floor if you if
you'd like to ask either of our uh
speakers a question or two please feel
free to do so or if you want to direct
your question to both of them then then
do so so um let's have a show of hands
who'd like to get get yes down here in
this this block over here please CH chap
in the white shirt with his hand up and
then should we have somebody over here
anyone over here want to ask a
question there somebody there he's just
pointing no this chap there's a chap
here with his hand up holding a program
so you go first sir I just wondered how
um Andrew would argue away the uh 3,000
prisoners he had executed in the Middle
East I which was which was considered a
war crime even in those days and we'll
take the other one here as well
yeah how he got to to stage
one where was he born how did he get to
be the general that he was or
could we have some background on that
well I think there's a probably have you
got one up there should we have a a
third one while we're at it and then
we'll my question is for for Adam in
particular Adam to what extent was
Napoleon bertier's glove
puppet okay let's start off with you
Andrew uh you better give us a bit bit
of backstory to start with perhaps on
his childhood all right yes uh well born
on the Mediterranean island of Corsica
he came from that interesting penumbra
between the upper middle class and the
lower upper class he was like a sort of
Highland Clan Chief family but they
didn't have any money um they were
officially Noble but um but they had to
actually get that uh confirmed he went
to school in Mainland France because his
father had confirmed him as Noble and
had a fantastic education at Brienne um
Military Academy and then at the the um
Echo military in Paris and then after
that he he followed the career of an
army officer whilst also at the same
time getting involved in Coran politics
which as Adam quite rightly pointed out
he was very bad at and uh they got the
the whole family got chased off the
island in 1793 what Adam didn't mention
also happened in 1793 a few months later
was that he commanded the uh artillery
at the siege of tulong and in a
brilliant um uh immediate appu as soon
as he went up to the uh to the top of
the eaglet above the of the uh Heights
of tulong he saw how if you captured a
particular battery you were able to
force the British out of the uh Harbor
which he managed to
do Adam you take your question now
gentle it's it's difficult to tell I
mean Napoleon all the ideas came from
Napoleon bet did put order in things and
he he was the the Workhorse I'd say of
the entire um military machine but I
don't think um as far as I'm concerned
I've never had seen any evidence of
Bertier
taking or even suggesting major um
strategic uh initiatives so I don't
think that he was um that is GL puppet
I'd say that certainly not um on on this
question of the origins um Napoleon was
of course famously insecure about the
whole business because the reason he was
allowed to to to to go to um got the
placement at a French military school um
was because his father became extremely
close with the French governor of
Corsica um the cour of Marb um who and
basically stuffed um Napoleon's mother
into Mar's bed um and absolutely no
evidence for that huge amounts of
evidence there is not and and the proof
of which Andrew is as you should know
Napoleon himself several times said to
people that he didn't know whether he
was his father's son or
M's no he did not say that he did say
that to some people he said it
to not least he was and so um he he was
quite insecure about that um and it the
other thing was that he started off with
this great romantic idea of Corsica as
an oppressed nation which he longed to
sort of liberate
um uh first as a sort of left tenant of
of the corsan Patriots pral pares and
then to sort of take over and then when
that didn't work then he decided that
Corso was become part of France and he
he while he was still at school he kept
saying I'm corsan I'm corsan I hate
France and when he suddenly realized
that power lay in France and that was
where the future was he became French
and that's that's really he he then
identified himself with the French State
the French Revolutionary State it's not
when he um actually thought that that's
where the power lay it was when he' done
his reading and understood the
importance of France the Enlightenment
and his own belief in Enlightenment
Concepts and reading of Russo that he
came intellectually over to appreciate
that he had that that cors was a um a uh
of course he believed in but was not as
important as The Wider
picture Andrew do you want to deal with
this question of his war crimes yes yes
very much I I mean I I I rather fear
that some people might mistake the idea
that this book is a hagiography that
doesn't uh ever criticize him he W of
course it does and the worst thing he
did was to um order the massacre of
3,000 prisoners of war after the battle
of Jaffa in March of uh of
1799 um these guys had surrendered to
him uh earlier in the campaign in um uh
when they were captured at Lish in what
is now the Gaza STP and he um and and
they gave their promise their perole not
to fight again and then they did and
were captured now of course morally it
was a monstrous thing to do but I would
take issue with the gentleman who said
that it um it counts as a war crime
because under the actual terms of Middle
Eastern Conflict at that time if you
give your parole and then break it your
life is forfeit it was the wrong thing
to do it was a terrible thing to do it's
a monstrous um you know moral crime and
uh and he was a ruthless man but that
doesn't mean any more than the things
that Peter the Great or Katherine the
Great or Frederick the great did that he
should be um stripped of the title he
deserves I'm I'm bit um worried by this
some comparison with Katherine the Great
and Frederick the great the only reason
they were called great was because they
paid all those lick spial journalists
like voler who flattered them um and you
know this you know I don't think it's
it's really relevant to bring those
people
in
um but I will here add also the French
um under Napoleon did treat their prison
as a war far better than the British
did right there's um let's have you you
gentlemen there with your hand up and
anybody else over here want to have a go
yes yes let's give it to the lady with
the glasses there and about the fifth
row back please yes go ahead could I
please ask both speakers what was uh
Napoleon's primary political objective
we've heard all sorts of things about
all sorts of his achievements or
otherwise but what was his primary polit
political
objective okay and we'll take that and
we'll take the the lady over there
didn't uh the abolition of primogeniture
by the code Napoleon result in a far
lower birth rate in France which
subsequently caused problems with their
Wars with Prussia and
Germany right then should we have one
more while we're at it yes let's have
one over here uh could you just give the
microphone to the chat oh we'll come
back to you sorry to the chat with his
hand up there well done you're passing
it along to him now there we are to both
of you militarily who would you consider
Napoleon's finest
Marshall right that's three things to
disc discuss uh what was his primary
objective do you think Andrew I think
his primary objective was a well
obviously um French of Germany in
Western Europe he was never he was never
attempting to rule the world he was
never attempting to rule all of Europe
either but he did want to ensure that uh
he was not going to be in any kind of um
of uh military or strategic Danger from
Austria Prussia or Russia um I think
that he also wanted to put the most key
um parts of the of the Enlightenment
into as many countries as he was able to
and Adam was absolutely right that the
uh that the the brothers of his were
pretty uniformly useless as uh as kings
but the reason was not that he bullied
them so uh so much was because it was
con there were constant Wars they were
Wars that were as I mentioned uh started
by the legitimist and oan regime Powers
not Wars that he
wanted what do you think his primary
objective was
um I don't think he knew that well
himself I think he meant well to begin
with and he meant he wanted order and he
he he
wanted he wanted to act he wanted I
think to um to to to rule and control
and I think there was an element of The
Sorcerer's Apprentice about the whole
Enterprise that you know he he would um
embark on one thing and then it would
lead to another and then he would and
this is I think his greatest fault is
that he lost sight of what he was doing
a lot of the time and you know by you
know
18101 um he's annexing you know he says
oh I'll have oldenberg as well and yeah
let's get Hanover in here you know part
of the French Empire yeah and let's
bring in Tuscany and you know he didn't
stop to think what is my aim and like
going into Russia he had no war aim he
didn't know what he was he didn't
prepare for you know if you're going to
go and try and do something about Russia
you say right you tell the Turks who are
currently at war with Russia that you
will that they should carry on fighting
and say you'll help them you tell the
swedes who have just had Finland taken
off them by Russia you say look we'll
help you you know you fight there and
we'll help you take Finland back no he
just sort of barged in Happily without
thinking of the consequences and you
know and that was the trouble it sort of
went on and on and it it became a great
sort roller poster and I think I don't
think he ever had a real um objective um
and uh certainly not a not a finite one
or a or a a completely
um you know it certainly wasn't thought
out and and I don't you know I don't
believe he sort of started out saying I
want to rule the world or I want to
trample everybody Under Foot that wasn't
it um he wanted to make his way in life
they all did these this these poor
corsicans they were terribly keen on
money making you know a future for
themselves creating an
establishment um but you know so there
was a personal um thing but the
political Drive was was rarely to
restore order and then things began to
evolve um and and you know the way that
I'm I'm sure that in 1799 it never
entered his mind to become emperor or
anything but that suddenly became the
obvious thing to do and there was a
horrible logic to it as there as there
often is Adam who do you think was his
finest
Marshall I would say probably
davu um and what do you think Andrew
undoubtly davu right and do you want to
deal with this question of the abolition
you've agreed on
something probably by
mistake damn I still not agree you on
anything it's too easy um what about the
abolition of
primogeniture um well obviously if the
code Napoleon um had nothing to do with
Napoleon it can't be blamed on him um
but but Adam is wrong about that that he
pres he presided over uh well over half
of the meetings that set up the code
Napoleon and when I say presided he had
something to say about absolutely
everything and he also provided most
importantly Adam's absolutely right when
he says that casseres was the um was the
intellectual force behind it but
casseres had been trying to get a code a
revision of the legal code into French
law since um the French Revolution broke
out and nothing had happened for 15
years what it needed 10 years sorry what
it needed 15 by the time it got through
was a driving political force willing to
cut the guardian knot and that's what
Napoleon was now with the question of
primogenitor uh which he himself of
course had his family had benefited from
um because that was the only way that
they managed to keep their States
together in uh in um in Corsica um yes I
think it's a uh I think it's a a very
bad idea I've always been against
primogenitor I'm the eldest um brother
and uh my younger brother who's in the
audience here is is is shaking his head
but there we are um the uh the fact is
that primogenitor is a way in Britain
certainly that you kept Estates together
and you um sent the youngest and poorest
people uh off to the um off to the off
to the wars but um I think to blame um
to blame Napoleon for the um what has
been blamed things that happened
literally a century after his uh death
um such as the the rise of German
nationalism at the time of the first
world war really is going too far and I
think the case is uh is the same for
primary genocide I wasn't talking about
the rise of German nationalism in the
first world war but in um
18113 well why was that such a bad thing
um it's it's only when it gets nasty in
1914 that we have to be or at least 1870
that problem it was quite nasty because
it was provoked in a very very nasty way
way by Napoleon because he went around
humiliating Germany in every conceivable
way the other thing we haven't talked
about I mentioned is is his appalling um
uh through censorship of the most
vicious kind his appalling effect on
french letters he basically um shut up
two generations of of of French
literature we are wildly um wildly
hypocritical about this the Lord
Chancellor had the right and exercised
the right to um to censor theatrical
Productions in this country until 1968
he did it against Arthur Miller's plays
pinder's
play well pretty much all the
anti-government newspapers and fact 60
newspapers yeah and how much how much
genuine it's wartime how much genuine um
uh freedom of the press was there in
this country in the second world war
when Winston Churchill said that um the
truth needs to be protected by a
bodyguard of Lies he understood exactly
what Napoleon was trying to do Andrew it
wasn't a question of it wasn't a
question of political things you know
Madame D wrote a book about German
literature you know it had to be
confiscated and burned the manuscript
was pursued by the police I mean the the
way in which you're treating him like
he's a madame daal uh was was sent into
internal Exile it is hardly a police
state when you have one policeman in for
every 1,510 Frenchmen in Britain today
we have one policeman for every 450
Britain does that make us a police state
no no I didn't think internal Exile is a
characteristic where police state isn't
it Jolly sight better than than being
put in prison at least he was able to
live in her vast and beautiful mansion
on the Lake Geneva the lake C imprison
oh fewer no no no no that's not that's
not the case the Onan regime and the
French Revolution imprisoned more people
than Napoleon right let's have some more
questions yes I'm sorry I should took
the microphone away from you in one two
three the fourth row back the lady in
with the black hair in black and and and
then you can give it to you had your
hand up in front just in front of you
and let's have let's have a question
right at the back
there
um you put your hand down now no you yes
you you waving your arm around with in
what color is your shirt blue
blue the man in the blue shirt
underneath the he ha put a new song in
my mouth even praise unto the
Lord
right and there's there something feeled
okay have we got another microphone we
can send over there in a second yes we
can right you go first then please thank
you may I ask both historians as
historians is it right that we should
judge Napoleon or indeed anyone from the
past by today's standards I mean how do
we how should we set this debate because
it strikes me that the things that have
been listed against him sort of
courtiers dis banishing people who are
out of favor military casualties all the
rest were very much of the time and how
people behaved at that time and yet his
virtues and the good things he did stand
the test of time and we're really
Forward
Thinking and also Adam zosi who do you
admire from the past following on from
that question is there anyone who who's
perfect
enough right yes you said at the back
yes you both um luckily agreed on who
was um his greatest General but as a
master politician and a diplomat I'd
love your views
on how you felt
ton
contributed okay and um yes go on um
this is a question for Andrew um what do
you think Napoleon's most likable trait
was have we got a microphone over here
now yes yes sir please hello hello yes
yeah go on
um hold up the microphone that's it
speak hello yeah um thank you from
Adam's description uh you wouldn't
expect um Napoleon's return on
Napoleon's return from elor that he
would
uh sufficient men uh to command a force
to restore his power to do whatever the
the rest of the um events that happened
until his demise you also wouldn't
expect um
the the Journey of his body to be lined
with people of France from the coast
back into Paris uh apparently a
continual line of uh people on both
sides of the river as his barge with his
body um came back to Paris and also that
Wellington insisted that he wasn't
executed when the I understand the other
uh allies uh were very much in favor of
that okay you might as well deal with
that first Andrew yes um the um the
return from elur there are several
things first of all he wasn't greeted in
southern France he had to avoid the
cities until he reached grobal because
he was actually um he met with
hostility um thereafter it was a very
mixed picture because and people were
jumping both ways it was a very tricky
moment and the reason it was a tricky
moment was because you must remember one
thing is that the bors came in and made
themselves unbelievably unpopular and
particularly with the
Army what's more in the interim while
he'd been in Elba all the prisoners had
returned from Russia all the ones who'd
spent the last five six sometimes eight
years in British hulks returned and they
were all still they they they couldn't
see the they didn't see the sort of
decline of France in 18121 13 and they
didn't feel the same way as most of the
population of France which was just sick
of the rising taxes um the endless
conscription um and the increasingly
bossy government um and so there was
there was a huge new Army ready to for
him to to to to take up as for the
return of his ashes in 1840 it was a
propaganda Thing by then you know two
generations of Romantic Poets and
writers had created the Napoleonic myth
which was something that is magnificent
and and and completely irrelevant um to
to the truth um has no bearing with it
and there was a desire for something
great because everybody was bored under
Louis Philip um and so that explains
nothing and as for um Wellington's um
generosity in this case that's um you
know hats off to him for it right um
this lady asked me um
about before before you answer that um
yes do tell us in a second but I'm just
before you do that that you have the
opportunity to vote now if you believe
that Napoleon should be called the
Great you insert the thing that says for
the black card into the box that's
coming around and if you don't think he
should be considered to be great you
having torn it in half you put the white
bit against and if you still can't make
up your mind despite the vehs of the
arguments we've heard this evening put
both bits in you or you can just Mark
liberal Democrat if you like
um so okay so who who do you admire then
Adam I admire lots of people but they
none of them are called the great um and
um I mean I there are things I do admire
about Napoleon in the end you know you
can't not but um not to the great you
know I mean there are things you admire
about some pretty F people and you know
somebody was asking about the role of
tahong tahong was the most frightful um
sleazy traitor who brought down I mean
he was absolutely frightful and yet I
hugely admire him because of his
intelligence um and you know I think
that I don't I simply
don't believe in wonderful great people
I think you know some people do better
or worse things and apparently did do
some quite decent things but they're far
outweighed in the historical context by
um I think his his what he did longterm
the fact was that he
he rarely eclipsed France you know
whether it was his fault whether it was
unfair who attacked him it didn't matter
you know he came to power in
1799 he put France back um brought back
a Prestige he then bungled everything to
such an extent that France was really
became not quite a second rate power but
was not the main player in Europe and
she should have been and Europe would be
would have been a far better place had
she been
and um he strengthened the tyrannies of
the East Prussia Russia and Austria um
which um created um as if you read my
book you'll see um um a a sort of prison
House of half of Europe um and right
sorry can I can I say a few words before
everyone's voted
um which is that Adam's absolutely right
that um that um Telly Rome was a sneaky
little weasel um who uh who financially
uh um bettered himself who betrayed
France as you say for money most of the
time but we all love him because he was
witty well it's um there are plenty of
people that were witty and one of the
thing one of the questions was uh from
the lady in the front there said what
was um what were Napoleon's um nicest
traits or best traits I think his sense
of humor is is uh something that took me
by surprise really he a Napoleon joke
I've given
I told you I told you three actually in
the course of my uh my okay uh the the
um sort of cool joke that he came out
with at the Battle of um uh vagram when
one of his ad Deon had his uh had his
hat is his shako um shot off by
cannonballs was uh which might imply
that he was a small man um said uh said
um yeah good job good job you're no
taller um but to make jokes during a
battle is amazing he actually went to
sleep for 15 uh minutes uh in the middle
of the battle of vagram where there are
a thousand cannons on both sides going
off and there extraordinary calmness and
coolness uh to this man which um which
took me by surprise but there 50 or 60
Napoleonic jokes uh in this book and um
it's an aspect it's an aspect of him I
wasn't uh I wasn't expecting
Pages it's hard going isn't it not the
reading of it for
fortunately uh and um the very
intelligent question from uh from the
gentleman over there um about Elba it
was quite um it's quite wrong to say
that nobody welcomed him into before
Grenoble um actually at lafrey he had a
regiment um fling themselves on him and
in um one of the other um Villages they
Sorry towns I think it was Sister all
they actually the common people of
France just of the town anyway just
pulled down the gates and smashed them
up and gave him bits of the gates to
show that they didn't want him to be
kept out of cyon so you know it's not
fair he's absolutely right when he says
that the B Bourbons ruined everything
and screwed everything up in 10 months
but nonetheless that wasn't the only
reason that people welcomed him back in
1815 what about this point that was made
very early on this very interesting
point about the standards by which you
judge whether someone's entitled to be
considered great or not are they the
standards of today or the standards of
the time your argue you've argued the
relativism right the way through your
presentation um no I believe in both I
believe he was great both by the
standards of the day and by the
standards of today but I don't believe
that um that really uh history makes
that much sense if you constantly just
see it through the prism of the present
day and the fact is that we have seen um
Napoleon wrongly through the prism of
the second world war again and again
he's presented especially by British
historians as a kind of Proto Hitler who
um was uh was a you know totalitarian
monster he wasn't you have to see him
through the um actual prism of the day
and he would have been a fan of the
European Union though wouldn't he yes ex
Andrew
Andrew day he was regarded as the ogre
as as a sort
of by the people who are fighting
against him but you don't have to Subs
to political propa years later at war
with everybody so of course they were he
had the sorry the largest attack that
ever took place in the history of the
Napoleonic Wars was when he had 21
states on his side going into Russia not
I know what happened there but the fact
is it was a bigger Coalition than any
that fought against him and the by the
way just at the time um in the late
1800s um in the you know around 1808 on
onwards um French women used to scare
their children with the idea the ogre
was com going to come and eat them
napolian so it wasn't just the English
well obviously none of the women that
made up the um 1 million people who Lin
the root 1 million people you've just
written off as mere propaganda I think
where your was your work well it's It's
Not Mere propaganda is it when uh a a
something like a quarter of the whole of
Paris turned turns up to see this great
man in there's a great spectacle and
there was a feast and they'd all
forgotten it so if they were trying to
scare their children why did they turn
up in the streets yes because no long he
was no longer a threat he was dead there
was a whole lot of ashes in there and
look you know look what happen and
people do people are ridiculous look
what happened when Stalin died everybody
came out even in the dominated countries
conquered countries of Eastern Europe
came out and cried in the street I mean
you know people do these things because
it's a mass movement doesn't mean that
you know they all thought he was
wonderful
well I don't if a million people come to
my funeral I'm going to take it as a
compliment you may have to wait for a
long
time right would you chaps like now to
make a final presentation for three or
four minutes about as to why people
should have already voted the way you
want them to
vote So Adam I think you should go first
really shouldn't you why he should not
be considered
great well I suppose I have to um I have
to um since you all now voted um I have
a little secret um which is I've been
commissioned to write a book about
Napoleon as
well and I'm pretty confident that um it
will be different in tone to the tone
I've taken this
evening
um the the fact is the ch's got to
eat the fact is that Napoleon was and I
think this is where Andrew so totally
wrong is Napoleon was a very very
remarkable
individual and the point about him was
that he didn't come from nowhere he came
out of a great ferment created by the
French
Revolution which itself was the fruit of
the Enlightenment and when the
revolution as it were hit the
buffers by
1799 most intelligent people in France
just realized this cannot go on and
everybody wanted some kind of a
different a third way they couldn't
restore the the the monarchy because
well you only had to look at Louis the
18th um and anyway you couldn't go back
it wouldn't have worked you couldn't the
Republic just wasn't going to go on so
they needed something else um and it
wasn't neonian who came along and said
hello there's me a group of people like
keres R and so on said look we've got to
change the Constitution create a
presidential Republic with the strong
executive power to do this we need a
general you always need a general um to
lead the pooran guard they chose
Napoleon they thought he would be a bit
of an acolyte he very cleverly realized
that it wasn't going to work it was just
going to be a talking shop and he very
quickly mused them out of the way and
took over and I believe that but he kept
them all of those who were prepared to
collaborate he kept on board and he made
went out of his way to keep a lot of
those even those who didn't like him who
are more leftwing than his him or more
rightwing more royalist to keep them on
board because I think the whole point
was that the people who created
Napoleon um who put him in
power uh wanted it was it was a joint
Enterprise and the reason that you know
it's extraordinary one minute they they
suddenly decide there must be a
consulate for life because otherwise if
he gets killed by some assassination
attempt and by the way Pit's government
was quite outrageous paying people to
Assassin him Center um you know the
whole thing would fall apart and then
the consulate for Life didn't seem good
enough because you needed continuity
what would happen if he got killed so
out came the idea of an Empire and he
they didn't think of the Empire because
it was grander than a monarchy than a
kingship but simply they couldn't call
him King because there had been the Bal
and it wouldn't look right whereas the
Empire and he was Emperor of the French
Republic so the idea was cesarian it was
they were going back this was the age of
neoc classicism they were going back to
Rome and this and that is why all these
as he says these Cafe owners Sons were
suddenly told that they were Prince of
this and Duke of that and that they had
to call him s and and stand while he sat
and so on that's why everybody joined in
this extraordinary fast in the
coronation with those ious clothes and
all that everybody joined in
because most of soth thinking people of
France said look we've got to try and
make this work and uh the I think the
greatest problem with Napoleon was that
he did lead that ovise and he did do
quite a lot to begin with that was very
good and he made things happen which
were going to happen anyway but couldn't
happen because there wasn't a strong
executive but then he actually betrayed
the Enterprise and then it was me me me
because anybody this is the awful thing
of absolute power anybody who simply so
much as declared a reservation or said
well excuse me S don't you think we
could do something this way or couldn't
we look at it that way was immediately
given the chill and they were out and to
me it was a great Enterprise a joint
Enterprise that went terribly terribly
wrong and I think it's very sad that it
did and I'm afraid the blame lies with
[Applause]
him right Andrew will now tell us why we
should have voted for the proposition
that Napoleon should be called the
Great ladies and gentlemen everyone who
put in one of these black little
cards is following in the tradition
of Gerta Hegel
BOS Byron carile the great intellectuals
who appreciated that he was a Bonafide
intellectual a connoisseur a Critic a
theorist of drama and music a man who
championed science who socialized with
astronomers and who impressed these
great men as well as all of those of you
who uh who were handed in this card he
was in the enlighten ladies and
gentlemen on Horseback he abolished
wherever he or his armies went they
abolished uh feudalism they rationalized
countries they abolished the Spanish
Inquisition um and uh all the all the
appalling backward things that had held
Europe back for so long under the
legitimists and the Anan regimes of whom
the spokesman it seems tonight is Count
Adam
zi um it's very it's wonderful news but
by the way that he's writing a biography
of Napoleon and I am very much looking
forward to reviewing it
um but when one sees the uh the the the
effects of uh this great man and when
they went into these towns one of the
first things they do like in the Papal
States classic example the Papal States
they where Jews still had to wear the
yellow star and where they were forced
into ghos he not only um opened up the
ghettos but he gave civil and religious
um rights and Liberties to uh the Jews
and to everyone else this is a
liberating concept the idea of the
Enlightenment on Horseback and for all
of you who um voted um yes you can feel
yourself part of one of the great
liberating Enlightenment Traditions
those of you who didn't of course uh are
are still uh stuck in the mire of
reaction legitimacy and the Onan regime
thank you very much indeed
[Applause]
well um Andrew um Adam thank you both
very much indeed uh we will await the
results of this vote which I think with
any luck is just on its way down to us
now
brilliant since you've been wasting your
breath for the last couple of minutes
it's at least polite to tell you what it
is
right well before people had heard the
arguments there were 49% in favor of the
proposition and 24 against and 27 didn't
know after the debate there are now
56% in favor of the proposition 43
against and 1% who don't know so at
least we've helped people make make up
their
minds even if it's come at the cost
apparently I don't understand how this
works apparent there's a minus 6% Swing
Vote against you in favor of Adam
congratulations well done oh boy it's
really good
fun book selling what the next
bit there are a worrying number of
Enlightenment people here though any
anyway thank you both very much thank
you very much to intelligence squ thank
you all very much uh for coming uh and
um until the next time and the books on
sale oh there are books on sale outside
here